we go what did you put fart fart fart oh
I've decided that I would have a lower
third how about this no that's that's
just for farts I briefly heard that you
guys promised that she would eat a bowl
of crickets if we raised $10,000 bunchy
that's a lot of fingers happening now oh
good as I can do I guess I probably
should have unzipped it my mom does not
know who you are
if you donate $10,000 in the next hour
Sara and I are going to cover our faces
in peanut butter but I got to take off
my shirt if I'm gonna dance this is the
perfect opportunity to confess my love
for John Durr
[Music]
keep your Batman mask on though so you
can be the masked Avenger oh never do
this unless you have explicit permission
how about my cheek is that enough or
should we do more so this group I had
this was a phase of time when I didn't
have a beard just to let you know we're
talking about but it's a hiney I dare ya
donk a donk is my favorite that's the
scientific term we're just a hundred and
sixty dollars away from a million Hank
so when we get to a million grace is
gonna dress up like a Christmas tree and
Sarah is gonna do my makeup and you can
do whatever you want it seems to me that
the donations have slowed dramatic
apparently everyone is getting an error
who's trying to donate right now we
crush all of IndieGoGo no one's been
able to donate in nine minutes we just
got a little bit we're inching
[Music]
Oh grace that makes it the star makes
thank you I'm a great actress I'm gonna
see the force the horse I like Equus
ferus caballus
oh whoa there's a word there art but far
so is your condo that you're a baby
no space alien obviously it is like a
little onesie I feel like I'm watching
something I think that's very private to
me the baby nor alien I was much much
man my two shirts that are very similar
where one is the top and one on the
bottom and you two can be but I'll
be right back oh my gosh amazing time to
be alive let's try you money says blood
fart on it there was a fog of runaway
burn down your house on fart miss day
and remember that we are all but farts
in the butt of let's party I do want to
say that we've we appreciate what you've
done to create this outlet we need all
of us to work together and say we're in
this for the long haul thank you and
your community for the time and for the
contributions you're truly awesome as
your name suggests thank you to everyone
so much for making this year's project
for awesome so successful and so awesome
we had six trending hashtags dozens of
guests who donated tens of thousands of
perks hundreds of thousands of votes on
over 900 videos submitted and we raised
1 million two hundred and eighty two
thousand seven hundred and fifty dollars
to make the world make a little bit more
sense thank you so much this community
is the best John I'll see you on Tuesday